Pete you have to pay for teams the pits
I thought you were a gaming channel come
on boots play some games
[Applause]
okay fine I'll play games I'll play the
best goddamn game there is in the entire
universe
[Music]
of course the bad
God is not pants a duty my tank and
ammachi oh wow look at that everyone
[ __ ] damn it
can i play here we go it's time to kill
old that's cheap there you go a nice
games would no one get J say why is this
a game
finally a good game everyone oh god oh
god I'm stuck I'm stuck return there you
go oh my god is that the Communists I am
I Russia my USSR oh my god Q the Russian
anthem
[Music]
Wow
just gotta watch out for boxes oh no no
no no no no no damn it
[Music]
let's do a shortcut
no I know we had the power of God an
anime on my site no no no no
[Music]
finally a game that doesn't undermine
the terror of the oil there's a glory
glorify the horrible things that goes on
in battle finally a game with realistic
teddy bears and you can shoot has
changed
[Music]
wait yes hello young lady we're playing
as a [ __ ] an anime [ __ ] really the right
tracks are here
wonder if there's any Swedish tank oh
that's right we are a bunch of [ __ ]
you know this game really makes you
think if war was just filled of enemy
girls
well then war wouldn't even be that bad
oh those are the Germans
am I the Germans I think I am great
fantastic you the German anthem please
[Music]